foreign
[Music]
Welcome to our session our panel on
large language models and the role of
data in training and tuning large
language models my name is Ali arsenjani
and uh
we have a very illustrious panel today
of Partners I lead Google's AIML partner
engineering and very happy that you can
join us here today
so I'm going to go around and have our
panelists introduce themselves starting
with yourself
hi everyone
I'm peroma one of the co-founders at
snorkel Ai and really excited for the
discussion today
my name is Ben blast I'm a product
manager at mongodb focused on AI and ML
and vectors hello everyone this is Chief
product officer for neo4j
of companies like neo4j mongodb and
snorkel AI here with us our partners in
our expanding ecosystem of developing
generative AI applications and AIML
applications in general so um one of the
things I wanted to ask you all today is
what are the use cases that you're
seeing that's resonating with your
customers and what what is the uptick
what are the key use cases maybe we'll
start with yusu dear okay thankfully for
the question and uh so uh I'm part of
neo4j neo4j is a graph analytics and
database company
organization use us for organizing their
knowledge into knowledge graphs in form
of entities and relationships and how to
bring all these Technologies together
and as we see generative AI capabilities
mature one of the things organizations
want to do is one democratize access to
all of the data that is available the
relationships and the information that's
there in the Enterprise so for example
uh one of the things that our customers
uses for is uh you know customer Journey
on their websites like how does a
customer come to the website how do they
Traverse through what they've done and a
lot of times there are a lot of
questions that need to be asked about
why did this person come and did not
complete the transaction in the cart or
something like that and today what
happens is the access to that kind of
technology is limited to experts who can
work with the data who can write some
complex queries and all and so this
there is a whole move to can we
democratize access to that using large
language models more natural language
experience on it another great example
is we're working with large
pharmaceutical company they have a
complex supply chain and so they
represent their whole supply chain as a
digital twin in form of a graph and then
like in Florida what happens if
hurricane comes what would be the impact
of that if like let's say you are unable
to go and fulfill from that distribution
center for two to three days what should
we do so those are the kinds of
questions you can ask now there are 300
people who can actually go Traverse a
graph and actually use graph tools but
with large language models and like you
know natural language we can extend it
to thousands of people in the
organization those are a couple of
examples of what uh what we are seeing
in the in the industry those use cases
that's awesome
um that's for neo4j knowledge crafts and
its relationship to large language
models
sure so um I work at mongodb and we have
Atlas the developer data platform and
you know our whole purpose is to make it
as easy as possible for developers to
build applications and there are
obviously a lot of new uh generative
tools in the space and we're looking to
make it easier and easier to consume
those
the kind of key use cases that we're
seeing right now are focused around rag
architectures right kind of bringing in
context learning so that you can build
chat Bots and support utilities we're
also seeing a lot of natural language
generation that relies on some Corpus of
private or sensitive data and then we
see you know generative Technologies and
kind of advanced embedding models
bringing about kind of improvements and
recommendation systems and anomaly
detection and so we're seeing a wide
range of of those use cases for you know
rag architectures we see a lot of chat
Bots you know large insurance companies
wanting to vectorize their knowledge
Corpus and have either their support
systems or you know something that a
customer can interact with directly use
them we also see a lot of kind of
specialized content generation so
something you would in the past have to
have an expert fill out a form now you
can have an expert use a tool to
pre-fill a form based on some Corpus of
information that gets fed into a large
large language model I think some really
interesting things around anomaly
detection uh like detecting if a car is
having a problem based on you know
matching the signal of its engine to
others then just personally uh you know
the headshot up there was generated uh
with uh degenerative technology because
I didn't have one so that was my
personal use case
it's a good wife man
I was about to mention that because you
told me if you didn't mention it
yourself
um uh so a little bit about snorkel
snorkel is a data Centric AI development
platform what that means is we help you
develop your data label your data
programmatically allowing you to do this
you know hundred to thousand times
faster than manually labeling your data
train a model analyze where it's going
right where it's going wrong and then
iterate and correct the data that you
have to get the best performance out of
your model so in terms of the use cases
that we're seeing I'll actually split my
answer into two large buckets
one really interesting one that we've
been seeing and working with customers
on is this idea of building your own
large language model kind of making it
customized given all the data that
various Enterprises have
um you know something that's become
really popular now because you have all
these large language models that are so
extremely powerful the kind of Major Way
that enterprises are differentiating
themselves and kind of getting an edge
over each other is the data it's the
data that they own that's what lets you
really own your model you know customize
it based on what you have access to so
people are building out you know
something I've heard this term gptu
making a large language model that they
can then use as a basis for all the
various Downstream tasks that you're
interested in in terms of the downstream
tasks you know we've worked on a variety
of use cases across a range of verticals
a couple of the financial institutions
we work with you know five of the top 10
U.S banks they're using snorkel and
again focusing on that data piece right
the part that they really own and can
customize to do analyzing reports detect
fraud in the Life Sciences base we've
seen things like doing clinical trial
analysis and you know using that to
improve demographics for trials that are
being run which has become a really
important topic recently and then
finally in the insurance space we've
seen people be able to again focus on
that data Centric way of developing
their data to create a model and you
know cut down on claims analysis Time by
up to 50
so this combination of using your data
to build models for a very specific
Downstream as well as these generalized
custom large language models for
Enterprises super exciting to see what's
happening in that space excellent thank
you yeah just one more thing to add
right I think one of the other
advantages that we are seeing is this
combination of structured and
unstructured data we've been talking
about it for a very long time but how do
you blend these things into a single
information set and do Discovery across
it we call it implicit and explicit
implicit is where you know the structure
we know the relationships and
unstructured is I have parts manual
sitting across the whole company in PDF
form how do you take those and also like
you know store it as vectors and have
the relationships mentioned so now you
can do a discovery of hey tell me
everything about a part that looks like
this and this has this kind of a
description and you can do a discovery
across the vectorized search plus the
relationships that are maintained in the
database I think those combinations of
that we're seeing that in oil and gas we
see that in some of the large
manufacturer for federal government for
Missions and stuff like that where you
have massive amounts of parts that go
into building uh like you know single
product and stuff like that that makes a
lot of sense you know combining the
unstructured and structured the implicit
and explicit as you termed it makes a
lot of sense to combine them together
because the information is spread across
the Enterprise so I want to uh Ben
mention one thing how many people have
heard of rag
raise your hand
okay fantastic that's excellent so uh I
didn't hear it I thought you might have
heard it incorrectly it's not rad it's
rag I'm kidding
and so with retrieval augmented
generation how many people are using are
you using retrieval augmented generation
raise your hand
very good uh it's it's it's increasing
everybody's aware of it that's the first
step but you know maybe uh 15 are
actually using it that's that's really
good now across the life cycle for a
building or leveraging generative AI
whether you want to customize a model uh
or leverage the data that you have on
Google Cloud your data is your data it's
not going to go anywhere else it's not
going to get leaked out
data models and embeddings and code are
preserved within the secure Enclave of
your Cloud environment and when we
interact across the life cycle you will
have very specific needs to interact
with Google's partners potentially for
various types of things you may want to
create a knowledge graph that go to
neo4j you may want to vectorize the data
you have to combine the structure
non-structured go to mongodb for example
and then if you want to prepare your
data for tuning and creating
domain-specific models we have snorkel
AI so but along this journey there are
challenges and I want to tap into the
expertise I have here on this panel to
tell us what your experiences are in
terms of the challenges and difficulties
that you're seeing your customers are
experiencing this time I'm going to
start with Barbara go ahead yeah
um all my answers are going to start
with this two-part split but you know
again being in a space where we're
seeing people really focus on the data
to build out their models there's two
broad questions that we see come up from
our customers that we talk to one is
what data do I use right you have these
generalized models there's they've been
trained on some amount of data that's
out there is that the correct type of
data you want to use for your kind of
Enterprise production level use case do
you need to edit it do you need to check
you know how it's performing on your
specific tasks do you want to customize
it again on the data that belongs to
your Enterprise another place where data
actually has a big role to play is
evaluation I think something we've seen
a lot with these generative AI models is
these really nice demos right you see
these demos you upload one PDF or two
PDF and it looks great it's amazing it
does perfect now scale that to a million
documents scale that to 10 million
documents how do you know it's going to
do well on each and every single one of
those one option is to you know you go
ahead and label 10 million documents
that's not feasible so you have to be
smart about how you're using your data
for this evaluation piece as well
another thing that's come up is this
this idea of bias if you don't have full
insight into the data that these models
are getting trained on you don't have a
sense of you know whether your model
might be biased or not you know there
are Parts there's things that the model
has learned that you might not want to
kind of pass on to your end users and
you your own customers so that question
of what is the data whether it's for
evaluation purposes for training purpose
and how Knowledge from that data is
affecting your use cases where you're
using generative AI That's a really big
open question and I think a challenge
that that we'll see as people start
using generative for production use
cases one more is how do you leverage
and you know especially with a sudira
and Ben were saying how do you leverage
all these different techniques that are
available to kind of push your knowledge
into these models there's ragging
structured data unstructured data
prompting fine tuning how do you know
which kind of method to use when you're
working with your data and when you're
working with your models and how do you
do that efficiently you don't want to do
this in a whack-a-mole manner right like
pick one okay let me try it for two
hours didn't work let me try another one
let me go back so what we're doing at
snorkel is really making that process
much more guided much more efficient to
to make it a lot more structured for our
data scientists and our domain expert to
be able to build these models
excellent on the data side on the
beginning of the life cycle when you're
curating and preparing data there's so
many concerns right you know you
mentioned bias in the data you mentioned
skew in the data potentially what's the
distribution of data that you need and
ultimately
is the data credible right is it
grounded in factuality so factual
grounding is another key thing
uh sure yeah so I think you know from
speaking to a ton of my customers I
would say the problems that I hear the
most break into into really two groups
one is is knowledge and the other is
tools and so the first is knowledge a
lot of people don't know you know what's
possible with you know these
foundational models that have come out
almost you know every engineer is being
asked to build something inside of a
domain that you know they weren't in you
know just six months ago and now
everyone you know has to have kind of AI
capabilities and so knowing what what
can be done and what should be done is
definitely a challenge the the other bit
about that is then all of the techniques
and
um kind of Concepts that you need to
understand in order to do a lot of this
work so for retrieval augmented
generation you know how do you chunk
your data
um
you know what is going to give you a
very good uh response back to then
include in the context that you provide
to your large language model these are
you know really challenging
um you know obstacles to get through in
order to deliver an excellent user
experience and kind of just alongside
that is the tools bit and so tools
there's all different types of security
and compliance concerns and you know
that's one of the things that we're kind
of eagerly interested in from a mongodb
perspective which is how can we make
some of those things just go away and
let developers build applications more
seamlessly and so that kind of very much
evolves out of the developer data
platform that we have but the reality is
that there are new tools and you need to
know about those new tools you need to
know how to use them
um you know things for chunking uh you
know there are the new Frameworks and
libraries that are very popular such as
the Lang chains and llama indexes of the
world that people are learning a lot of
these Concepts out of then in some cases
putting to use then needing to again
kind of operationalize and and use and
so
those are kind of like the two groups of
challenges that we see most frequently
and what you know my customers are
saying to me
I agree with both of you and I will just
add a couple of other points I think
number one is it's it's about grounding
or hallucinations right so everybody is
worried about what happens if the answer
that is coming back from large language
model inaccurate and what do we do how
do we ground it how do we make sure it's
accurate and this is where separation of
concerns kicks in about what goes in
large language model what's going to
stay in the knowledge base within your
organization are you going to ask llm
for a questions answer and then validate
it are you going to go ahead and just
basically use it for vectorization and
then ask get the actual facts directly
from the knowledge base and then use
large language model for more natural
experiences so that is the whole area
and there's a lot of back and forth a
lot of open questions for for customers
people are trying both different ways we
see in the phase one of this journey I'm
pretty sure innovation in this space is
going to only grow faster and faster but
in this phase I see the separation of
concerns and how you got into grounding
better so that's one area I think is
there the second area from a data
perspective is the day data in
Enterprises changes all the time and
training large language model on the Fly
is not possible in the context of your
prompt and the session you can go ahead
and have some level of information but
the facts are changing all the time and
so how do we make sure where you should
do which decision making and this is
where we need better guidance for
everybody and from our perspective it is
how do you make like you know factual
information versus natural language so
that is one area I think is is coming up
again and again and the third one I will
talk about is there are a lot of
organizations and we work with some of
the largest federal government
departments and all that and they have
this air gapped kind of an environments
and so in that scenario then what model
do I run how do I run how do I develop
somewhere but not use the data that is
there and that you mentioned about data
secure to your data is data that is a
big concern for everybody and then how
do we solve for that together I think is
going to be the third one I will mention
awesome one one area that I think uh
don't forget what you're going to say
that I was going to ask sudiron is so
this this Confluence of knowledge graphs
and llms how does that look like what
language models together with knowledge
graphs I think there are two aspects to
that right one is if you believe all
your Enterprise knowledge has been
captured in a Knowledge Graph and where
you know what the facts are and all and
you know large language models are great
at generative languages like you know I
I always talk about when you went to
school it was like English class and a
math class and math I learned about here
is the formula applied this way
otherwise you're going to fail and
English was like be more creative and I
have tough time being creative so so I
think the two different ways of thinking
and I think I think about large language
models a great way to continue teaching
it getting it better and better but it
is built for generating new information
and new things out of the existing
information and then knowledge graphs or
knowledge bases are a great way of
factual information and the way they can
come together is one you can train
models better when you know what your
entities and relationships and what
things are there but also grounding as I
was saying like making sure that you use
the actual Enterprise no knowledge which
can be updated in real time and you can
keep everything current and that becomes
your factual responses and all that and
I'm looking forward to more innovation
in this place with Lang chain around
tooling and can you go ahead and
integrate both of them more seamlessly
and all that but that's I think uh
better coming time that's great and
spoiler alert we have a Blog on that you
can you can look up
two things I wanted to double click into
I think on the topic of knowledge graphs
and grounding
um Ben actually called these models
foundational models right and they're
foundational for a reason it's because
they provide a really good basis but you
have to build on top of that you know
pull in Knowledge from these knowledge
bases knowledge graphs something that
we've seen a lot of our customers do is
use ontologies especially in the medical
field right so you have ontologies you
have these knowledge graphs then you
have just domain expertise you know
we've had clinical researchers use our
platform to build end-to-end AI
applications how do you combine all of
that while taking advantage of
everything that these large language
foundational models give you is really
important the
I wanted to double click into was
adaptability right the amount of data
that these models have been trained on
you cannot go back and change that every
time you have something new come up
um one of the banks that we worked with
during covid you know certain policies
changed and they had to adapt their
model if they had gone back and just
changed the data to fix their model it
would have been six months in today's
day with the type of models we have
that's you're talking years right it's
just not feasible so having those
efficient ways like we've seen with
snorkel to be able to adapt to changing
business needs to changing data
distributions SKU like you'd mentioned
earlier that becomes really really
critical in this time
one thing maybe just to add to this is
um you know something you just mentioned
Brahma about kind of adaptability is
what we see as being really interesting
with regards to some of the large
language models is the fact that you
know us as developers and Builders want
to expose new services and Suites to all
of our users right
um but you're not going to take all of
your users data and train one model and
turn it loose on all of your users right
so so it can tell you know me that I
have blonde hair that would be unhelpful
um and so what we see you know happening
in the future is the use of databases
with Vector search to allow you to kind
of personalize the responses from models
in a very secure way such that you know
your session with this model can have
context about you but that model is only
accessing that data within the context
of the session within within which
you're interacting and never elsewhere
right and so that also gets to the point
of like where you want to think about
kind of maybe find tuning a model or
making it better at handling some tasks
but never you know releasing an
individual's information inside of that
and kind of you know kind of polluting
those two different needs which is
really kind of one security and privacy
and the other you know making something
more performant for a certain set of
tasks or characteristics yeah I
absolutely I think to kind of draw a
summary if I were a long large language
model and you would prompt me for a
summary of what you all said I would say
that as an expert in knowledge graphs
and vectorization and data preparation
there's this spectrum where you can do
prompt engineering it'll take you so far
you can do retrieval augmented
generation or it's variations like flare
fetch you know look ahead
um by by having a factual grounding in a
knowledge graph that you look up at
runtime so to speak before you give it
to the model you can have vectorized
capabilities as Ben was saying where
you've already created the embedding
toward the embedding possibly combine
the structure and unstructured data so
that when you're doing the retrieval you
can have access to that data but all of
these would be possible if the next step
would be if you fine-tune a model if you
see this recurring over and over again
on the same domain it might make sense
to find two of the model as apartment
was mentioning which is the ability to
take that model and just teach it enough
in that domain so that you're not
completely doing a full fine tuning
you're either doing an adapter tuning
speaking of adapting or doing something
like a low rank adaptation capability
where you're creating a smaller model
that can satisfy your needs in the short
term and you don't have to you know
shoulder the burden of a large language
model that's where a cloud provider like
Google can support you but give you the
ability to create those adapter models
for your specific domains and then let
leverage the capabilities of our
partners here at each stage across that
Spectrum did I capture that okay yeah
okay I'm just a large language man very
accurate
so as you as you take this journey
forward in your products and your
journey with your customers what are you
what are your plans or how are you today
building on top of the Google AI
platform in order to accomplish your
future
uh kind of needs I'm going to start with
Ben now and then I I'll it's a 50 50
slit who goes afterwards
very just of you
um yeah so we're thrilled with
everything that's coming out of vertex I
AI we're you know super excited about
the model Garden for us what's kind of
you know closest is the new embedding
models like Gekko which are Super
exciting for us to use inside of our
Vector search offering and so uh we're
going to plan you know deeper uh and
more easy to use Integrations and kind
of further enable our developers to take
advantage of these new technologies then
large language models broadly
um you know we want customers building
applications we see them kind of driving
a lot of new applications being built on
the platform and so making it easier to
consume those Services utilize you know
Google's various Services inside of
vertex AI is kind of directly aligned
with what we're trying to do and so we
see a journey you know starting with
embeddings uh and getting you know much
deeper there and then moving into large
language models and and further
awesome thank you
now this is going to be a surprise to
everyone I'm going to give the audience
a quiz a very short quiz what is the new
EST window size that you can input into
a palm model
if it's is it 4K raise your hands is it
8K raise your hands is it 32k raise your
hands you guys are awesome and fantastic
it's 32k awesome very good so are you
guys by the way uh now when something is
output of the of a large language model
what about that token size how many how
many K's of tokens is it 1K tokens is it
2K 4K or is it 8K tokens yes it's 8K
don't don't hesitate we have 8K tokens
coming out
and that's sold to the gentleman from
kidding yeah
yeah excellent so we have 32k context
Windows 8K outputs and hugely enhanced
models that are being constantly updated
now with that I'm going to go to
Parma
um I one of the things I was going to
highlight was the inference piece that
you would actually mentioned you know
large language models are really great
when you want to build a large number of
kind of specialized uh task specific
models on top some of the customers
we've worked with they just want you
know one very specific use case you
don't need all the knowledge that's in
these large language models you don't
want to bear the cost of kind of the
inference and everything else that comes
with it so they've started distilling
these models for just the knowledge that
you need and having you know Google AI
and the Integrations that we have has
made that much simpler right it's it's a
one-click kind of process to go from
tuning one of the largest models to then
distilling it down and having that
flexibility in the platform due to the
Integrations with Google has been
amazing
um one very personal story I have to
share is when we started with snorkel
one of our first real use cases was with
Google ads so this partnership has has
been there for decades now and something
that's very very close to our heart you
know being able to see how real use
cases were being built you know what the
kind of pain alongside data the data
challenges back in those days whereas
and kind of really learning from that
has been great the last two things that
I'll mention is again similar to what
Ben says the integration with vertex AI
with bigquery that's been really great
and we also have someone from our team
actually integrating Palm as well you
know and trying to see if you can take
some of the prompting from gen AI so I
know I'm going down the laundry list but
that's that's really to say you know
there's been so many products from
within the Google space that have been
so wonderful to integrate with and work
with and something that our customers
have you know repeatedly been really
really excited about awesome excellent
so before so there goes my second quiz
of the day so one of the problems that
we have in large language models is they
hallucinate so the antid or at least the
mitigating strategy for that is factual
grounding how do we do factual grounding
on large language models so you
typically do some kind of a you access
it via Knowledge Graph you access a
vector database you have a tune model
you go out and do retrieval augmented
generation but that factual grounding
needs to be there so today we announced
how many types of new factual grounding
is it one type of factual grounding or
two types of factual grounding raise
your hands one or two
I feel like I'm in the eye doctor is it
one or two it's two types thank you you
got it two types of factual grounding
one for Enterprise search and another
for a different capability that we have
so factual grounding is something that
we need to leverage in terms of
knowledge graphs in terms of vector
databases in terms of the retrieval
augmented generation that we have so
that we can ensure or at least try to
increase the probability that the data
is that coming back from the large
language model is credible data so let
me answer it in two or three phases
first one
super excited about the core data
platform that Google has the security
the governance the VPC boundary the axt
all of that because every Enterprise I
talk to they're all about how do you
secure my information that's the biggest
thing the second is on the vertex side
super excited about model Garden because
no one model is going to be perfect for
every use case having this ability and
it was interesting to see the Llama
model available it was a great demo that
nunchar did there but I think that one
having optionality is super important
because we all have different needs and
all and then the the app builder was
super interesting you can build a
conversational uh like an application
pretty quickly I think that's super
helpful for us our customers so those
are the three capabilities the two
different things we think about how we
will use uh like the vertex AI
capabilities for our own uh product
enhancements and so in that the biggest
thing I'm excited about is we are
looking at building our own uh like you
know fine-tuned model because we have
our own language in in neo4j Cipher many
of the graph databases actually support
Cipher as a primary language it's
similar to SQL but more for graphs but
it is a different language so having
like a customized model that is actually
optimized for that which we could open
up to the whole industry is a super
exciting thing for us so building on top
of one of the other code models that is
available Palm two maybe or one of the
other ones by llama code one that's
available so so that is one area super
excited and then that augments into
assisted development how we can go ahead
and do simplifying learning Journeys for
our developers and stuff like this so
that's one area and then the second area
for for the Enterprises where this is
really relevant is how can we give more
natural language chat experience more
easily on on their knowledge that they
have created so without them having to
build the whole environment train and
then fine tune and all that so I think
one of the things we are excited to
partner with Google is can we go ahead
and take the knowledge graphs and like
you know automatically create fine
tuning on top of that so we can do that
and then customize the models for them
too so those are a couple of areas super
excited on the where these things goes
next that's a very Cutting Edge set of
innovations that is awesome
[Music]